Venezuela's opposition leader has called
for nationwide protests to coincide with
his return to the country one way though
has proclaimed himself acting president
and is recognized as leader by more than
50 countries in a tweet released over
the weekend he called on people to
gather at locations throughout the
country at 11 a.m. local time
that's about now why they left Venezuela
last week to travel to Colombia and
other countries to garner support for
his bid to overthrow Nicolas Maduro
Maduro has said guardo could be arrested
on his return now on sunday guardo
released an online message calling on
its followers who take to the streets
ahead of nationwide demonstrations the
regime believes that this is the moment
when the movement loses its strength but
it's the opposite tomorrow we will
return with much more strength to each
and every single streets of Venezuela
tomorrow we will return with much more
strength to each and every single
streets of our country joining me now is
DW correspondent Xavier our goddess he
joins me from Bogota the capital of
Colombia javi what is the latest on why
this very bossy was in Colombia is he on
his way back home to Caracas do you
think well that is most likely the case
I'm Rita we are expecting him to do the
same thing he did when he left Venezuela
which is crossing the border in to
Colombia and then be supported by the
Armed Forces here that's why many said
that he was in Colombian territory last
night already spent the night here and
is now on his way either to the
Venezuelan border or directly to the
capital Caracas the information about
his travels has been extremely scarce
because of course he is under threat
there are many security risks so
information about where he is headed to
and how is very very difficult to attain
especially when we saw for example his
travels out of Ecuador yesterday we did
know that he departed with a plane from
the
Dorian Air Force but there was no
information about where the plane was
headed to so that is why hints are more
likely that he's going to be in Columbia
and then in Caracas as he should appear
at least in theory in one of the many
protests he hopes to organize today we
are looking looking at pictures of Juan
why though right now as he was speaking
Xavier and they will expectations that
he would be arrested on his return why
was that a risk for him well because he
shouldn't have left Venezuela in the
first place there was a travel ban
dictated by the Supreme Court of
Venezuela that prohibited him to leave
the country so when he appeared in
Colombian territory last weekend or the
weekend before that to attend the
concert that he organized to support
humanitarian aid deliveries to Venezuela
he was already breaking the law he had
to cross the border illegally from
Venezuela to Colombia to attempt the
concert that let's not forget was in
Colombian territory so now that he is
trying to get back where he already did
perhaps he will probably have to do it
the same way crossing the border
illegally now if authorities noticed
that or somehow intercept his operations
well then he should technically be
arrested because he broke the law that
is at least the discourse that we have
seen from Nicolas Maduro but that is
going to be very difficult to do for the
Maduro government because he knows that
there is a lot of international support
and very clear threats especially by the
United States that if anything happens
to one Widow in Venezuela and territory
that he if he is arrested that there
will be very extreme consequences we do
not know the nature of those
consequences but we cannot discard a
military intervention and that should be
something you've got as my Lula should
be worried about so we will probably not
see an arrest at least not immediately
and perhaps not on the charges of having
left the country illegally naquan Vidal
had been coding on demonstrators to come
out on the streets and we were seeing
some live pictures of people gathered on
the streets in Caracas now what is the
opposition hoping to achieve with these
protests well they have to send very
clear messages of unity and of support
to choir
why do and this is something that is
very important we could say that it's a
pivotal moment for the van as well in a
position because we have seen opposition
leaders come and go many times in
Venezuela now almost always at the
beginning of the year and then nothing
really changes and these figures seem to
disappear that has happened many times
when as well as know that and for those
who support the opposition they also
know that if the opposition fails in
changing the government they will
probably face consequences meaning more
oppression by the regime of Nicolas
Maduro that is why it is very important
for them to gather today to show support
for one widow a figure that has not
really succeeded in his last missions
let's not forget that the concert he
organized barely collected the amount of
money that was needed and desired he did
not manage to get the humanitarian aid
into the country so that has definitely
weakened his position as the alternative
to Nicolas Maduro we'll see what he
manages to gather today right javi
engages in Bogota thank you very much
for that update
you